no one is born
white what are we
doing what a question for us this
evening can white people be
saved what what is going on let's talk
about the Sleep Gap did you know that
black Americans do not sleep as well as
white Americans do the Center for
Disease Control and prevention conducted
and published research in 2020 on sleep
in the US the results showed that 43.5%
of black or African-Americans had
trouble sleeping compared with
30.7% of white
respondents black and latinx people in
the US spend 15% of their night in deep
Sleep which is the most restorative and
regenor phase of sleep compared to 20%
of white
Americans poor sleep is a public health
problem whether it's because of
historical stress maltreatment or health
inequities black Americans do not sleep
enough and poor sleep is a feedback loop
and the effects of poor sleep mean
you're more likely to get bad sleep
again this sleep Gap is worsen for
people that are lowincome disabled or
undocumented looking back to the
enslavement of black people in the US
fatigue has been used as a measure of
control against black people this is why
several campaigners and academics are
pitching sleep as an act of resistance
for the black community to rest even to
take naps is an act of self-care is an
act of resistance so this Black History
Month to any black person watching this
video remember to
rest
I had no idea what this
going I had no
idea if these people didn't take
themselves so seriously they'd be the
funniest
[__] you know the thing is I
was really listening to her I was too I
was like mhm
mhm I was really listening to her and I
was like
mhm mhm mhm and then curveball
uh it's an act of resistance cball Act
of
resistance imagine you're on the job and
people are like yo stop sleeping on a
job I'm
resisting no [__] you're
fired and you're
talking I'm talk you talking to someone
that used to sleep on the job when I was
at Rogers yo [__] that I mean listen I
couldn't sleep well so my [__] was all
[__] up my
sleeping I was stressed I didn't like my
job I had hard time to sleep so I could
fall asleep anyway my pressure was so
[__] low and stuff like that but yeah
why did you shoot him cuz he was
resisting arrest he was
sleeping but I I get
was you know what I think the problem is
I didn't these people they have to use
the most extreme language oh yes to
describe like it's like yes we're going
to stop lynchings in America and that's
how we'll resist Supremacy I'm like okay
take a nap but that's how we'll resist
super I'm like you putting everything in
the same [__] M I was listening I was
listening listen there may be ra racial
reasons why inequality exists but the
reality is people don't sleep well
because they have multiple jobs or
because they're hyper stressed because
they don't make much money I'm sure if
you did the same study and just put
people on based off income black people
would probably be on par if not very
close to white folks in that regard that
are poor it' be a class thing more than
anything right yeah um it's just it just
shows shows you like poverty is a [__]
when you not making money when you got
to work mul multiple things or odd jobs
just to make ends meat it [__] up your
sleep cycle and like what she said about
sleep being super being a super detri I
can speak to myself cuz for a long time
I didn't sleep well both because of my
medical condition which over represents
uh for people from where I'm from but
also um just because of like trying to
make ends meet as a gig economy worker
like it was very hard to have a good
sleep schedule so one day you're going
to bed at 4:00 a.m. the next day you're
going to bed at 400 p.m. because you got
a gig at 2: in the morning or whatever
it might be so it's hard to get good
sleep and when you know I know what it's
like to not get good sleep and then I
know what it's like to transition the
difference is n day the differ between
sleeping and not sleeping like for me I
was much more personable I felt more
present I was much more aware my memory
was better my performance was better
everything just becomes substantially
better so it's a compounding issue where
you're already pouring you're struggling
then you can't get sleep so it's hard
for you to get the leg up like it's all
real things it's just a lot of these
activist types they code everything in
extreme language makes you turn off it's
like in order to defend white supremacy
we need you to take a nap my brothers
and sisters straight from Zulu Nation
you need to get sleep to connect with
the African
spiritualness [__] like that's why I'm
saying the first half I got it's a nap
[__] yeah it's a nap it's important but
it's a important but make sure you take
a dooo cuz holding it in makes you hold
in all those negative emotions from a oh
my chill the [__] out tell people the
[__] you don't need to link everything
to the craziest widespread oh my it's
just it's a lot it's it's it's for real
it makes me it makes me not listen to it
yes telling me to go to sleep is not
going to make me go to sleep that friend
came to me and said oh well you know
what really works uh you could take a
like a chamomile tea and I was like if
that was if that was that would solve my
problem it wouldn't be a problem okay
that's not an issue oh you know what you
could do to the you know for your
problem of sleeping sleep that's not
don't tell people that they need to
sleep that go to sleep that would have
of course the lack of sleep is a symptom
to a bigger problem okay they cannot
why they cannot sleep why telling them
well you can't sleep go sleep that's
going to solve it it's not going to help
anything yo uh Abba are you free to film
at 4 no I got to fight the
power Jesus Christ that's how we're
always going to find sleep now yeah
fighting them yo what you doing well I
went home and then I fought the power
for two
hours after that I had the more errands
to do that's a good power fighting
pillow right there fluffy and
[__] these we
wild is that your mattress no it's a
tool of
resistance hi quick reminder we have a
Discord join it I'm in
there a question for us this
evening can white people be
saved what what is going on
golly what is going on today bro what's
going on with your videos I just want to
know I just want to
know if you're saving them white folks
on the low cuz we just can't take it
anymore no one is born
white what are we doing
[Music]
what okay that's what are we listening
to that's a funny bar that's a funny bar
I suspect this is like a metaphorical
thing no one is born an oppressor but I
think he's just trying he's being okay
first off he's being slam no but hold on
he's slamming the metaphor hold on put
me like put me on game who's this dude
uh he's a professor at Yale Yale that's
a professor at Yale apparently Yale div
School I don't know what that is yeah
bab School div DV do not tell children
that no one is born white there is no
white be
biology but whiteness is real whiteness
is a working a forming toward a maturity
that
destroys whiteness is an invitation to a
form of agency and a subjectivity that
imagines life progressing toward what is
in fact a diseased understanding of
maturity a maturity that invites us to
evaluate the entire world by how far
along it is toward this goal yes I want
to
change the
geography
because that is the only way that is the
only
way to move us from this Vision this
trajectory toward toward
death and most importantly I want to
save people that's a pastor that's not a
did you see what he said and most
importantly I want to save
people from becoming
white w wow yeah wow yes M no more
whites 2024 wow mhm no more Tuda cassos
we [__] him all of them no more white
supremacy let me breath I'm tired of
resisting I'm tired of sleeping yes I've
got nothing want to save you from being
a
white I got nothing you got nothing I've
got nothing but the whites got
everything and I think you haven't made
the connection he trying to save them
from being white cuz he understand that
isn't right they was born into the
oppression they was born into the
oppressor role no cuz nobody's born
white no they're not born white but
they're born at the privilege peep the
game you have to understand it's not a
matter of skin it's a matter of
environment cultural conditioning and
the future that we're gazing upon
is wider than a canvas but it ain't
blank it's already been painted your
shackles are there you can't see them
but you can peep
them let me see your arms let me see
your
arms that's a fist shackles let me see
your arms let me see your
arms tattoos shackles he drew them on
himself this brother been lost but it's
okay because even though they may have
been born that way it's time for Lady
Gaga to change your future but she's
white but she wasn't born this
way
theu get the [__]
out get the [__] out take all your [__]
get the [__] out no unacceptable this is
unacceptable oh [__] get the [__] out of
here no unacceptable it's okay
unacceptable nobody has to be born this
way
unacceptable all right so that's it for
Ababa Zulu King
thei making sure that all you heard the
words that's coming out there
hizzle fisel manle
whizzle anything you'd like to say more
hisle absolutely not no hisle no no wear
no bird no drizzle sprinkle a little bit
of a fizzle right over the mike hizzle
are you good E 40
you do a good e for I'm not going lie
you do a good e
for sprinkle a little fizzle a little
fizzle Dizzle tell me where to
go all right anyways uh this got some
cheese got some G that's some silly ass
goofy [__] they were saying up on I
don't know he said a whole lot of
nothing he said a whole lot of nothing
let us know what you guys think in the
comments below were you guys born white
no why did you guys choose to be white
tell me where they go Jesus Christ I so
Shake him